[Music]
Runk well guys what is up I tell you
what I'm about to announce some new
dates in a little bit here I think in
November I'm going to do that for all
for next year uh but until then we got
Long Beach November 2nd November 10th
Orlando Florida November 12th Fort mys
Florida Richmond Virginia November 17th
Baltimore Maryland Trenton Philadelphia
and reading P oh reading p pvan and then
we have Oxnard California in December
get your tickets now um crystal.com and
we've got a beautiful merch here that we
like to uh oh well we got we got merch
we also got have more merch coming which
is ridiculously cool I can't wait to
drop it but uh this will be the last
probably chance to get a lot of these
here we got the pockets stay Jeep and uh
we've got a bunch of different
collections uh here
um uh we got the uh the grower die the
life rips and uh the cult my favorite
the cult flannel there go to Chris
lea.com and pick it all up and uh that
being said let's get into the newest
episode of
[Music]
congratulations my hair's too long
officially my hair is too long
officially dude and Lulu Gonzalez the
feat the person who features for me the
great comedian who features for me told
me that she liked my hair good when it
was short that's a diss in my book but
we still love her she actually said uh
why don't you do your hair like that
actually do my mom would do that [__]
wow that's hilarious Chris why don't you
do Chris why you do it so it's like
Chris why
you and how do I receive that when I'm
11 I'm not good enough but it's all good
dude it's all good I'm I'm you know I'm
being like I'm joking I love my mommy
she's great she's doing good with her
hip surgery uh she's out and about just
doing her thing she's great I love my
mommy and um and that's it um I was in
let's
see uh Cleveland pit I was in Pittsburgh
Cleveland and then uh Detroit oh I
forgot dude I was gonna [__] talk
about it on stage on on Detroit about
how that
place every year they do some kind of
dorky festival thing that that they do
at the theater I was at and they weren't
doing it this year and like people
online were like thrashing me because
they're like it's because of you we
can't do
our I don't even understand how to
describe it and I don't even know what
festival it was but it was like some
Festival where they do the masks with
the Eyes Wide Shut nose that come out
those that dorky [__] you know like the
mask with the dorky dick
NOS with that music in like a
cathedral um and with like cloaks and
then they had like you know that that
stuff with the pants that are
like like like a g like Jester pants
that are belled up above above the knees
just dork [__] man just absolute dork
stuff and here's the deal dude I they
were happy to have me the people at the
theater because I sold it out they would
if if if the if the festival was making
bags then they wouldn't have had me do
that weekend it's not my fault I didn't
even know about the dorky ass weekend
until you know people were thrashing me
online so there you go dude I forgot to
talk about it on stage they honestly
it's probably better I didn't because
the people in the audience wouldn't even
have known what the hell I was talking
about because the as is so dorky dude
and that's a radio at it um so yeah but
I was in Pittsburgh which dude oh well
first of all I mean first of all
American Airlines I didn't know you
sucked what's going on American Airlines
you United you suck are you United did
you hire some cats from United to come
over and operate your uh
business American H first of all have a
direct flight from Los Angeles to
Pittsburgh yay dude Pittsburgh too is
too big of a city to not have direct FL
yay and don't just have Southwest or
Spirit Airlines have more options yay
dude conspir don't have a plug to plug
in your charger do so you so your phone
dieses on the flight yay he dude I
didn't take SP
but dude so we took American okay dude
and it's like um I took American and
like um I had to connect so
like and like I did it and where did I
have to connect Dallas no that's too far
south naturally now that's too far south
to go up there I gotta go Pittsburgh I
go back down there that's too far south
dude is it yes
dude so I went to Dallas oh and I got on
the plane in Los
Angeles and I'm on American now here's
the deal American some of your planes
really be banging they really be great
and some of your planes are just
absolutely regular from
2001 update
it hey hey hey update it okay
so I'm on the plane and we're sitting on
the plane for 45 minutes and guess what
here's a real kicker we're not in the
air yet oh oh yeah dude so I'm not
steaming really until I get a text
message from my tour
manager uh in on the plane because we
don't we're not sitting near each other
hey we're going to have to book it for
our connection and I go like this I
forgot I forgot we got to book it to the
I forgot there's a
connection dude
so I
go we finally take off 45 minutes in and
I'm like we're not going to make it and
he's like we'll make it we just got to
run
so we they do the thing where we land
and it's like where they're
like ladies and Gentlemen please there's
some connections so if you could not you
know get off the plane if you don't have
a connection the people with connections
are going to be trying to make it cuz
they we really were [__] everyone so
they're going to actually we got to make
it really we got to we got they're going
to have to run we're they're going to
have to [__] run hopefully they're in
tiptop shape shape because the Dallas
airport is actually 17 miles long and we
will never ever ever make sure that a
connecting flight is the next gate over
we'll never do that so what we'll do is
we'll have to make it so it's four miles
away so you have to take a tram and
you'll have to judge whether or not
running or taking the tram is quicker
and no matter what you choose you'll be
wrong okay so ladies and Gentlemen Just
make sure if you don't have a connection
just just sit tight and you're not going
to listen to this okay thanks
bye so I'm like all
right we [__] get up of course
everyone gets up not just the people
don't have connections I got to boot
pass everyone I'm the first guy running
I take the tram get there okay now dude
yes he looked at his watch yes because
he was Technical and yes he wanted to
[__] Stick it to him on the podcast
yes
dude the flight was at whatever 35
whatever hour it was 35 that's when the
flight was yes
dude he got to the gate at whatever the
hour was 27 he's got 7 minutes now
now you got to get there earlier than
that I understand I understand and I get
the rules you got to be there 15 minutes
before to have a [__] shot to get on
the plane what to to have the you just
got to be there right there's still a
shot you can make it if you get within
15 minutes but maybe not so I get there
and the lady at the gate is like sorry
it's closed and I say oh come on dude
there was so many people on the flight
that I was on for
Pittsburgh there were so many people on
that flight to Pittsburgh so now what
they gave away the seats oh they gave
away the seats so now they give away the
seats to the people who flying on
standby so now it's better for them for
their pockets they don't give a [__]
about our hearts yes dude they don't
care about our hearts they don't care
about our souls American Airline you
only care about the
pockets so I say I walk up to the lady
and I
say they say you got to go to gate
whatever 24 to get the you got to go to
gate 24 to for them to that's a customer
help so I go to gate 24 it's not
customer help
dude it's not customer help customer
help is next to gate 24 but she said
it's at gate 24 so guess what I do I
wait at gate 24 because I know that the
person at gate 24 can fix the problem
and I know that's not what I'm supposed
to do but that's what the [__] lady
said so I'm going to play by the rules
in case it doesn't work out it's not my
fault
dude so I get there and she says is your
name Chris and I say yes she says can I
get a picture with you and I said well
can you help me she says oh well let me
see if I can my son loves you and I'm
like you're not even the one that
[__] loves
me okay she says well what happened I
said well they said I can't make the
thing and I need another another flight
to Pittsburgh so can you please put me
on another the next closest flight to
Pittsburgh and she say o I don't know if
we have another flight to Pittsburgh
tonight and I said I bet there's a way
to figure it out she says I don't know
so she
goes and she
says
dude she goes she
goes oh no dude you
dude
hey hey hey class who wants to be
talking to someone who's behind a
computer and they
go oh nobody's hands
raised because that's the worst position
to be
in no one wants that
oh and I say what and she
says you know when something happens
and you think how how many times in your
life have you have has something
happened and you immediately think oh oh
so I'll never forget this
moment there's only before and after
right there's this moment that's
happened and you never know the moment
that's going to happen because the
moment comes you got to grab it oh and
it's away oh here comes the moment you
don't know when it's coming but it
happens you're like whoa it came and it
went by oh no
that's seared into my brain
now she says to
me
ah is there anywhere else you can
go I'm I
I'm I'm in Dallas right now I need to go
to Pittsburgh she says is there anywhere
else you can go
like what I just what I'm I going to
just instead of go to work take a trip
to [__]
Aruba what do you mean oh well I'll just
change everyone's
lives and I'll go to
Ottawa what do you mean can I go
somewhere else dude I couldn't believe
the words that came out of her mouth
that I didn't even respond correctly she
said is there anyone where else you can
go and I said
me that's not even a response to
that like I I don't know if I even
thought like is she talking to someone
near me I'm making sure I I think I was
thinking I I have to make sure this is
me in this situation right now so I said
to her me and she said well there's no
flight to Pittsburgh today it would have
to be tomorrow and I said well I can't
go anywhere else I have to go to
Pittsburgh and she says
well H there's a real early well you can
can you go to Raleigh oh hey
no do you want to go to Raleigh tomorrow
at 700 a.m. and then
Pittsburgh anti
I'm anti that absolutely not what pull
me in Pittsburgh hey I need to be where
the Pirates play hey I need to play
where the be where the Penguins play hey
I need to where the where the Steelers
play Hey Pittsburgh you got too many
teams oh come on give me to Pittsburgh
[__] I didn't say it
wanted
to a come on
[__] didn't say it would never feel bad
I even said on the podcast but it's a
joke I don't think women are
[__] but give in
Pittsburgh so she
says I don't think there's anything we
can do and I say I bet there is
so now I'm talking to my tour manager no
no so now I'm like well she's like why
don't you go over to customer service
I'm like all right [__] this I'm going
to go to customer service maybe they
have like the extra special way to deal
with it by the way the lady was so nice
I'm playing she was so nice but that's
what happened and it was ridiculous what
she going to do [__] make a plane
come out of thin air
and so uh cuz you know you do the thing
where you're like can you get the
manager you know and then the manager
comes and they're like oh well there's
actually it's like just tell me all the
[__] up front let me deal with the
person who's the most the person you
know if the manager can't do it get me
the owner if the owner can't do it let
me talk to a plane you
know how may I help
you wow Robin Williams
so so
uh so now I'm like okay I go to the
customer service and my tour manager
like you know we have a
flight he's like oh I just talked to the
he on the phone right because you got to
do all sorts of [__] if your flight gets
[__] up you got to call and wait when
you're waiting in line if you're waiting
in line and you're not calling someone
else also trying to fix it dude you
might as well now build a house where
you are cuz that's where you live you're
not getting
out
so so uh so we get to um the the
customer service and and he's like dude
there's a flight to Cleveland later in
like an hour we could just take that go
to
Cleveland and
um stay in Cleveland
tonight and
then tomorrow drive to Pittsburgh do the
show come back to Cleveland and then
stay for Cleveland and then this
way you don't have to even really do
another drive that day you have the
whole day in Cleveland and I go oh dude
and that's why we play the Rust
[Music]
Belt it's why that's so good when you
get to [__] fly in and ding ding ding
and fly out because that's what we did
because we did [__] Pittsburgh and
Cleveland and Detroit because oh that's
why we play the rust
belel oh it's so great man Cleveland
changed Cleveland's changed last time I
was was in Cleveland was four or five
years ago went to Cleveland where is
everybody where'd they go Cleveland had
great food where' the restaurants go
they had great food then the restaurants
where are they they're not there anymore
not the ones I went
to and there's lots of more homeless
coming around and [__] Cleveland has too
many oh I'm wearing the wrong watch
great I got a [__] gold ring with the
[__] thing I'm an
idiot but um then I did Detroit
and I was on
stage and I was talking about Marvel
Avengers and
[__] and some lady in the back goes says
I love
Marvel and it's like what kind of person
does that
dude don't say
that you know there's 1,700 people in
the audience somebody just says I love
Marvel in the middle of the show L loud
everyone heard
it like what it's not we're not having a
telephone conversation it's not me and
you in a room it's 2000
here um so we did we flew into Cleveland
stayed in
Cleveland uh went
to
uh bro when are cities done you know
there's always
construction cranes and [__] and places
where you can't walk you know oh [__]
the fence watch out you're doing [__]
like that dude it's there it's never
done
man it's probably better to live back in
the you know 900s besides dying and
people thinking that people were witches
and stuff and
like you know you die from like a
fever like you didn't didn't have to
worry about like updating everything cuz
there just wasn't [__] to
update the wheel [__] everything up
huh the second of guy is like look at
this put 40s on
there we all we're [__] we went we
went
[__] and now when I go to aroan or
grocery store I got to like move out the
way because they're changing the
plumbing or something in the parking
lot it's all good this is just you know
big uh first world problems but it's
like you know they're my problems so
it's like okay the shows are fantastic
dude we can watch the the tour report is
up
um dude how
about how about could you have you like
this dude first of all
Lithuania is
just why wouldn't you do this if you're
from Lithuania he's
Lithuanian you know
he is a man who is arrested for faking
heart attack 20 times to avoid paying
the bill at restaurants
dude his name Isis J El Lithuanian man
living in Spain okay cool yeah wow cuz
Spain you can't you know what you can't
do that in America you nobody would give
a [__] oh [__] he's got a heart attack
oh [__] oh [__] here oh put the bill
under him
here put it in his pocket the ambulance
take it away put it dude what first of
all what a
debacle to to to not pay $25 for like
some beef
sliders you know to just and then fall
down and then have to go to the
hospital or what happens after that he's
oh I got heart I got a heart attack I
got to go or what what
anyway have big bigger
aspirations
crook you going to go to jail after 20
times faking a heart attack the
50-year-old man a Lithuanian National
identified as Idis
J in in Spain they they don't oh no look
what he did he is going to he die he is
going to die forget
it that's I can't think of it but son
what is uh he's going to die
oh
no help him please it is on us and
America be like that [__] that's still
$32 give me
um Isis was first arrested in his scams
November 2022 and his most recent
encounter with the law was on September
19th dude he still did
it you know this this guy's going to die
of a heart
attack
I want to know how much yeah here we go
in his latest Target the Shameless
scammer visited the el Buen comr in the
historic district of Alicante Spain for
dinner and ordered a seafood paa and two
whiskies which cost roughly 3680 oh dude
he tried to skimp out on
3680 when he finished his meal and
drinks the man attempted to leave but
was stopped by restaurant staff who told
him he had to pay at first Idis who has
gotten the in game El
gastro said he needed to go back to
hotel to get the money and then claimed
he felt unwell and threw himself to the
ground dude uh I need to go get the uh
uh my my money in my hotel sorry sir you
can't leave we we need to get we need to
get paid um
uh it was very theatrical he pretended
to faint and he slumped himself down on
the floor the restaurant's owner
said they didn't buy it I love
it dude they took a picture of him on
the ground and he's just like
this and he knows he's not even heart
attack dude I love
that
wow how much time can you get for that
in America you'd get out the same day
anyway wait wait wait is this it the elb
oh there's the the
restaurant oh I wish they had video of
it falling down softly so it doesn't
hurt himself you know 42 days because of
two unpaid fines 4 to days not worth
it boy who cried wolf Lithuanian boy who
cry wolf That's So
Gangster
um this is something I actually can't
even
believe I I don't even like could you
well if
bro there's natural disasters you know
which it's like oh [__] like youever see
the footage of like tsunamis that come
through it's like devastating but you're
like okay well this is nature I can't do
anything about it charge it to the game
you know charge it to the nature game
like we're [__] oh no like you know uh
dad got hit by lightning oh that's
brutally terrible but charge it to the
nature game you know oh [__] there was
an earthquake and then things started a
volcano erupted and got some
houses and they're gone oh [__] charge
it to the nature game though you know
nothing you could do it Act of God oh
[__] there goes nature cucking around
you know what I'm
saying there goes Mother Nature vengeful
that's why it's a woman Mother Nature
cuz you know women are vengeful and so
um there'd never be dude nature you know
there' just be it would be I know dudes
do war and [__] but when it comes to
natural disaster if it was father nature
everything would be so plush and
beautiful you know mother nature mother
nature they they got tsunamis [__]
earthquakes volcanoes uh uh storms and
[__] cuz women are vengeful and it's all
good I didn't make up the
rules this is Mother Nature oh really oh
really humans tsunami starting in Japan
hitting the coast to Cali just oh oh
really just Mother Nature just like this
in the
wave all the way miles until
it's oh no it's that vengeful [__] okay
that's twice I Ed the b word well but
she's not real
so here's here's here's the thing man
nature be toodling around with its [__]
you
know like I said tornadoes there when it
comes to wind ones there's five of them
anyway Cyclones tornadoes hurricanes
like dude you know Mother Nature is
having fun out there no this is a
different like uh yeah it's not just wi
this one will twist around like a
[__] this one will twist around and
look like an hourglass and pick up cows
and [__] houses
and you know what I'm saying oh and this
one's a hurricane it's just a mess
completely our cars will be
upended
humans I don't even know what a cyclone
is but like there's there and I'm not
even naming all of them and then they
have categories this one category
[__] you know four [__] it [__] them
they shouldn't live in Alabama anyway or
wherever they have them I don't even
know where they have
them
um so but then when it's human error
when you lose [__] because dude this
headline just says
it okay so here's the deal this is what
the headline is woman returns from
vacation to find family home mistakenly
demolished an employee admitted he had
the wrong address after he checked the
permit
but the company has taken no other
action dude they demolished the
ladies
House in Atlanta dude this would only
happen in Atlanta Atlanta is
crazy you
know I
mean imagine coming
home after a
vacation dude like you spend your hard
earned cash that you [__] you
know you're like oh man finally get to
go on vacation GNA relax just G to all
my stress going to be gone by the time I
come home ready to ready to get back to
life and just rock it and you show up
dude and it's a pile of rubble okay that
happens to me hey dude check this out
that happens to
me everybody I've ever met in my life is
getting
murdered okay I don't I don't give a
[__] who has whose fault it is everybody
I've ever met in the world is getting
murdered okay people I met when I was
seven I got to go back and find John
Middleton or whatever the hell his name
was when I was used to be friends with
him my mom was like that was your first
best friend I don't even remember his
[__] full name I think it was John
Middleton or something but he was blonde
whoever that guy if he's alive he's
getting [__] knifed up
dude sorry dude I came home for vacation
lost my home the [__] there was the
wrong address dude and the guy's going
to get stabbed and as he's getting
stabbed he's going to be going like this
I get it it's extreme but
I the [__] the [__] blood coming
out of his mouth I I would do it too you
must be murdering everyone you ever
met
dude could
you IM I can't wait to just walk through
the door of my house and just plop down
on my couch and just start rocking life
again what a great great reset and then
you don't even have a door to walk
through or a couch to plop down
dudee
imagine driving
up imagine first seeing it a little bit
far away you're
like you're like oh no that's not right
right that's not our it looks like it's
our house like but you're convincing
yourself no no no it's not I can't no no
no no get closer that'd be
me oh my god dude I can't that is the
it doesn't work the oops
button look at her look at the quote I'm
furious hodin said I keep waking up
thinking first of all where are you
waking up is this all a joke or
something just a choke because here's
here's the thing too that happens I go
to oh I'm I'm rich as [__] I'm getting
rich off this somebody's getting sued to
high heaven you know what I'm saying I'm
going to be yo it's going to be Chris is
going to be like you're going be like
were you seen we seen Chris lately nope
why ah he's just like [__] he's doing
the ducktail [__] where he dives into
the [__] the the cash from the diving
board he's got that now oh really yeah
oh he's somewhere I haven't talked but I
was his best friend oh but he doesn't
talk to anybody anymore only his family
and he he spends [__] eight hours a
day off a diving board inside diving
into some coins like [__] DuckTales
who's DuckTales was that Scrooge McDuck
that's Scrooge McDuck that's me I'm
changing my name to scog M duck that's
how [__] much I'm suing and getting
money for
it oh my God she asked a n she said a
neighbor called her while she was away
and asked if someone had been hired to
DARE tear down the vacant house I said
no and she said well someone well
there's someone over here who just
demolished the whole house and tore it
all
down hey
neighbor stop it before that
happens worst neighbor hey hey guys what
you
doing when The Neighbor confronted them
hod Hodson said the workers got nasty he
told her to shut up and mine her own
business oh dude that's not even their
business mind your own business I'm
[__] destroying the wrong
house
oh my
god oh would I would get so many
millions of dollars all your pictures
for everyone they're all gone you know
your all your [__] is in there like
computers and
clothes oh
man uh all right right
well dude I you know what I so
Halloween's coming
up
uh which means one thing BuzzFeed is
going to put out some stupid [__]
articles you know what I'm
saying um so here it is I found it the
other day 31 Halloween costumes that are
so clever I'm kind of jealous I didn't
think of them first first of all too
long of a [__]
headline like by oh by the way you can't
there going to be so many Barbies and
Kens that I'm I'm I got to stay in
because I can't be seeing that [__] I
can't be seeing some fat Ken you know or
some like plump Barbie some chick that
thinks like she's getting away with it
when it's like they were going to make
the Amy Schumer Barbie movie if they did
okay but they
didn't you know so be Cru uh the [__]
the the bad lady in Ariel in the [__]
the the pink the the purple fat lady you
know what I'm talking
about
um but look look at this I dude I the
worst Halloween costumes are are the
cute things are like the ones where
you're
like uh a [__] bird and you're
attached to somebody painted blue and
you're like look I'm chicken cord on
blue or whatever the [__] you know or or
or or you're in a dress and it says
Freud and you're like I'm a fru idian
slip like I that stuff is dude that kind
of [__] is so cringe and I'm just like
oh nah hey ah if Halloween is the thing
where you get creative if that's the day
you get creative just give it
up like here we go ghost Malone this is
one of them no no no no just
no I mean a
bumblebee why is a bumblebee something
that you're
jealous I'm not even going to go there
pumpkin spice
girl I mean whatever you
know oh no be Yonce a be that says Yonce
on it I mean come on dude look at this I
just look at this dude this lady's
dressed up as a chicken with a bra and
money under the bra a chicken strip dude
I I just said the [__] chicken C on I
didn't even read this
yet a white
claw oh God and she's a crab with a
white
claw oh dude no this is the worst one
I've ever
seen this lady has a shirt that says
blessing on it and sunglasses and a hat
and a Overcoat it says a blessing in
disguise
dude no
my mom would be like oh how funny no
dude a copy cat oh oh dude this has
futian slip on
it this is
hilarious this has the actual one I was
like is so [__]
stupid it she's wearing a slip dress
that says libido
psychos ego mom ID oh god dude I
mean a [__] a nun with a briefcase
and it's she's none of your business
dude oh my God put a [__] dildo in my
anus repeatedly this is just ABS
dude use one of those [__] the SNM
things where you're you're where I'm
tied up and it just
goes with a big dildo raming in my butt
dude sorry I know my dad listen to this
podcast but come on
man yo this makes me feel bad these
things here's another one a spice rack
and she's got just a bunch of the Spice
Girl dolls around her neck on a on a
wood plank a deviled
egg Beauty and the Beasty Boys oh I'll
[__] [__] all over
dude oh
dude a web server oh dude she's got look
and she blurred her face out cuz she
knows it's stupid she she's got a dress
with a bunch of spiderwebs on it and
she's holding uh a a a uh like cocktails
on her on her tray like a server a web
server
dude fantasy football dude this guy is
wearing a patriot Jersey and has a a
wizard beard and a a a
staff
bro
Jon Snow White I will I'll start a whole
singing career dude I I can't this is so
insane bro are you you don't like these
right oh he's he's he's on he's on
another team he goes I mean no
dude a dill
do oh like a d and a dill oh oh
god oh the friend zone dude are you
kidding me dude are you are you are you
kidding me the friend zone and they're
dressed
up
like people who do construction and
they're together I guess I don't know it
doesn't
matter bro these get worse these are
unbelievable
check this one out a formal
apology dude she's got a nice dress on
and a sash that says apology if you have
to
write the word on
it hey just go as a witch hey just go as
a
ghost just go as the
president you know be babadook for
[__] sake I'm G to keep
going
oh God old the mermaids and they're
they're mermaids and they get the saggy
tits
no oh this is crazy bro a fly swatter s
SW it's a SWAT guy with a
[__] a shirt that says SWAT with a FL
I'm jealous cuz that's a low maintenance
outfit that's pretty good that's what
I'm jealous
of oh dude the Adams Adam Adam Adams
Family so
I don't even want to do it it's an one
guy's an atom atom one
guy's I don't even get
it Hell on Wheels okay well we got to
give her a pass because she's a
paraplegic and she's the de and she's
the devil so good good job lady even
though you
know aom B with a be with his be really
get some mileage with that Darth slay
a
woman with a
d I don't I don't know you got to be a
mom for like 12 years to appreciate this
stuff you can't just be like if
you I love how mad this guy gets this is
so
great come
on come on here we go
wait I have to sign in for this guy I
need you to be quiet right now sir what
are you going to do I'm going to evict
you from the hotel and I recommend you
get out of my face what Nathan call
bro first of all the guy's so drunk and
second of all that guy behind the N who
says Nathan call 911 would not win in a
fight dude he would be so exhausted from
jump
he's already
exhausted guy I need you to be quiet
right now sir what are you going to do
that guy so drunk what are you going to
do you from the hotel and I recommend
you get out of my face what Nathan call
911 use his
diaphragm dude use his diaphragm Nathan
call 911 love it I want to be that guy's
friend for real
dude I I was watching this thing last
night with Kristen and our
friend and uh it w and it was um the
Zodiac Killer the new documentary Zodiac
Killer thing or whatever you know it's
like two
episodes and this guy is talking about
the the um Zodiac Killer and the whole
thing about this miniseries which is two
hours it's two episodes they're each
like an hour and some is
is that he is like he you learn when you
watch the thing is this is the guy who
has this Theory that's nobody's had this
Theory before but or I've never heard it
but he's
like he basically says there was no
Zodiac
Killer and it was all separate murders
that separate people did and once the
news and the media started running with
the Zodiac Killer thing
people would start to kill who they
wanted and just do the Zodiac Killer
thing because they know that they'd get
off because they wouldn't be
investigated for the other murders and
even if they fit the description for one
murder it didn't link or jive with the
Zodiac Killer theme so they would get
away Scott free this was this guy's
theory he wrote a book about it and I'm
like first of all genius if I ever to
kill someone I'm writing a Zodiac Killer
note to you know what I mean whatever
cuck
ass the rolling rolling stone or like
[__] whatever woke ass [__] cuck
ass [__] that's going to be out of
business soon or the LA Times you know
just hey uh I am the Zodiac Killer I I'm
sorry here I had to kill you know the
guy who my opener or I mean Chris is
opener because you know whatever it
is and here's a crypt cryptology thing
about it and just put some random
designs and like penises and a and and
like a [__] fish and like dildos and
[__] and tits and they just are like oh
wait we don't know what to make of this
you know and they can't show it in the
news but there's another crypto crypto
cryp thing whatever they call it uh but
the guy was like bro first of all he has
a shirt he's wearing a shirt with
[__] like one of those Hawaiian not a
Hawaiian kind of a Hawaiian shirt with
uh pineapples and flowers on it and I go
best friend from now on best friend
everyone else gets moved down a notch a
guy like that in his 50s who wears a
shirt with pineapples and flowers on it
best friend immediately okay so I'm
watching this and the guy the guy the
documentarian puts it to him he's like
so what you're saying is there's no
Zodiac Killer and there were just random
killings that were trying to uh uh that
were that were one-offs that that you
know and and and and the Zodiac killer
was a literary um design that people
just fictionalized and the guy goes like
this the cuz the the documentarian put
him to him he's like to put him back on
his heels like the guy you would think a
normal person would be like well I mean
the facts come you know if you the guy
goes like this looks at the dude and
says big go and I fell in love with a
man
romantically that's that's the kind of
[__] confidence I want to have man
and I mostly do but sometimes you get
[__] up you
know like when I was talking to the uh
flight
attendant cuz there was no Wi-Fi in a
flight and I wanted to say Hey where's
the Wi-Fi and I wanted her to be like on
back on her
feet be like well we don't have we don't
I said where's the Wi-Fi and she said
you don't know we haven't had Wi-Fi for
a year on these planes I I
go she got me I want to have that
Bingo
confidence and if you don't have Bingo
confidence let me tell you something
dude you don't have passion in your
life you don't have passion you're
living your life dayto day you might as
well be a z zombie zombie
zombie dude I'm good but yo you got to
have that Bingo mentality that Bingo
confidence look people in the eyes when
I'm talking to someone and I need
something or if I just you
know I people oh you got Charisma
whatever yeah I could use that if I want
but guess what sometimes I don't
sometimes I imagine eating the person
I'm talking to his face
and that's a straight up 100% life hack
for
you I'm imagining eating their face okay
say whatever you want oh chryst is crazy
oh Chris I don't do it and I never would
but I imagine doing it because if you're
imagining consuming someone when you're
talking to them you win no matter what
happens CU even if you don't get what
you want you go like this ah whatever I
ate you in my
head you got to imagine picking things
off their face and eating all right well
we'll get demonetized I'm not a serial
killer but all I'm saying
is
yeah that's that Bingo mentality I don't
know if the guy from the document
documentary would agree with
me but I'm just like you know what's
Bingo you know what's Bingo Ean call 911
that's Bingo mentality
dude Nathan call 911 he sang it you know
that's the beginning of a of a of a song
in a musical he does that and then it
goes
BL like that's
how that's how dope it was watch Nathan
call
911 where you going shut
up oh he's in the car oh
no
it's beautiful
man
um I guess it doesn't always work out
when you're that confident right
because I did when I forgot my bags and
she said there's nothing we can do I
said I bet there is and I looked her in
the eyes I still had to go to
[Laughter]
Cleveland you still have to go to
[__] Cleveland I love Cleveland man
I really
do say whatever you want man I love
Cleveland Nathan call 911
blank stream Tomorrow's Hope by Peter
Clark on Spotify now go to my page if
you want to purchase a 10-word ad or a
shout out of some sort holler. bab
christalia um oh yeah this
thing this is incredible
this is
incredible dude this was hip-hop is so
it I look I get it hip-hop's cool but
it's also so kind of dumb you know like
you're just
rhyming but they'll act
like
the it's so funny to me that they act
like it's hardcore and it's just rhyming
like especially the in the cipher when
you're like battle rapping and people
are like oh like that's just the word
that's just like you know let me just
strap up my boot and turn around open my
ass for a too you know
oh I go to the bar I take a car oh [__]
people are just like godamn it and
people look at me like I'm a superstar
and you a stupid star
oh like dude you have kids
bro you know what's your hey hey Guy
what's your real
job you know you're a bank
teller I may be a bank teller but I'll
shoot your ass like oh Yeller
oh and make more money then Rockefeller
no you won't you're poor you know it's
like uh I thought it was dumb until I
saw this
guy to take it there cuz when I'm about
to do the Bob Dole
Bob and Ras it Square oh
dude SpongeBob dude I mean come on dude
cuz if y'all ain't never heard of
chrisan rapper I'm about to take it
there cuz what I'm about to do the Bob
doodle bob me h
dude first of all the doo Bob doob I go
whoa I I go like this nul and then he
goes the illst bar of all
time C if y'all ain't never heard of
Christian rapper I love it because he
starts with the Christian rapper thing
and then just it's out the
window
Doo and he's doop you know what I mean
he's like really putting it to him this
is the Bingo mentality he's got but he's
saying
O a lunatic I'm about to take it there
lost his mind cuz when I'm about
to still hanging still hang on to some
semblance of his [__] former self
after he said the dooot part the second
time his brain literally separated and
it broke his cerebellum dropped and the
[__] uh what do they call it the the
thing that um the [__] uh the
midbrain ex it just swolled up and the
the sides of his brain hit his skull and
he's
hemorrhaging and this is what happens
right after
[Laughter]
that dude
oh [__] frontal lobe is what I was
trying to think of dude God damn
it it is yeah dude what's with the
[__] things I'm predicting in this
podcast
I It's a
SpongeBob you put it on there yeah oh
here's the SpongeBob reference okay hold
on oh doodle
bob people in the comments were like
y'all don't even get the [__] levels
of this it won't be
[Music]
me a look at him a a doll all he needs
is a
tie Squidward daning the
door what just
[Music]
happened oh dude that's pretty ill man
that's a good bar so what does he mean
then I'm about to take it there what I
do to Bob do to Bob if
don't and take the square whatever the
[__]
whatever it was stupid still you know
you still have a regular job somewhere
um what Michigan State showed Adolf
Hitler's image as part of a pregame quiz
on video boards before playing number
two Michigan on Saturday night and later
apologize for the improvie well what
what about it though what did he say
Hitler and Austria's birthplace flashed
on the video boards long enough for
someone on social media to share what
was seen by
fans well what did they say you can just
you can show someone
right
um wow dude so now
they're so now what see this is the
thing nothing happened
right did anything happen or people just
got mad and then they apologized it was
part of a quiz it's not like they were
saying you know you know what you can't
say um wow that is pretty weird though
Look At That Somebody explain the cont
behind this for context behind this for
me just straight up Hitler on the
[__]
Bor it's just
and he's just up there with his little
ass dumb Mustache Boy he really ruined
that mustache didn't he Charlie Chaplan
was like I'm going to kill this [__] and
then Hitler came along and they were
like all right well I guess we're done
with that remember when Michael Jordan
had it in that [__] haes commercial
the little Hitler mustache what the
[__] that was wild wasn't it um all
right all right that's good we
appreciate you guys um thank you very
much uh and uh I will be in like I said
um uh Reading Pennsylvania uh Long Beach
Orlando Fort Meyers Richmond Baltimore
Trenton Philadelphia and Oxnard coming
up and stay tuned for some new dates
appreciate you that's it for YouTube If
you want to get the rest of the episode
The uncut episode uh go on to
patreon.com crystalia and also you get
all of the other uh bonus episodes that
have been going for years you could
watch them immediately for just six
bucks thanks a lot
[Music]
guys